[Music]
i allow my brain to do the work to get
into my creative zone when i have a
problem to resolve sometimes i just
sleep on it and i let my subconscious
mind
work through resolving problems and
solving problems our brains are always
at work like trying to be
fragmented break apart the things that
we encounter
so
i spend a little time thinking about how
i can approach things creatively
and then i spend a little time not
thinking about those things and allowing
my brain and my subconscious mind to
have an opportunity to do the work for
me a lot of times when i come back
afterwards i've got a great idea i've
got the answers and i have new ways to
solve and resolve things that i've been
thinking about to get into my creative
zone i do something that i'd like to
call productive procrastination
i start what i'm working on way before
it's due and then in fits and starts i i
work
well giving my mind permission to wander
to things that absolutely are not on the
agenda
it's encouraged
some of my most creative experiences
some of my best songwriting educational
videos and even scientific breakthroughs
while i was supposed to be working on
something totally unrelated and this
won't work for everyone but my mind is
most creative when it's free to go on
unplanned adventures
good music also helps a great playlist
to me is worth its weight in gold my
playlists are special because they only
include instrumental music
and songs in languages that i don't
actually speak so my thoughts don't get
too pulled into the lyrics themselves